durant toute la seconde partie de
l'année 2020 le cessez le feu en vigueur
dans le donbass était globalement
respecté mais la région connaît ces
trois derniers mois une escalade des
tensions sur la ligne de contact
et la tendance n'est pas franchement à
l'optimisme le porte parole du kremlin
constate que les modestes réalisations
accomplis jusque là ont été réduites à
néant
au début du mois de mars le président du
conseil européen en tenait la russie
pour responsable et estimé qu'elle ne
tenait pas ses engagements engagements
qui sont pourtant écrit noir sur blanc
dans les accords de minsk la seule
feuille de route reconnu par toutes les
parties prenantes au conflit
comme le rappelle dimitri peskov et nous
les mènerons nos jeunes en profitent
pour madrid il ne faut rien compliqué il
faut tout simplement examiné et relire
ce document pour constater que
malheureusement kiev ne les a pas
appliquée en outre un document a été
signé à l'issue des négociations qui ont
eu lieu à paris il en va de même la
plupart des accords n'ont pas été mises
en oeuvre
voilà ce qui a été dit en réponse à la
question du journaliste à cet égard
pourquoi l'autre partie ne respecte
t'elle pas les dix accords c'est une
question qui doit être adressée à la
partie ukrainienne et l'ukraine à la
russie continue donc de se rejeter la
responsabilité de la non application des
accords de minsk et c'est la population
du don base qui en paye le prix
la population rendus plus vulnérables
encore par la crise sanitaire
la pandémie de co vide qui a entre
autres fait passer au second plan ce
conflit qui dure depuis bientôt sept ans